in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche bella find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape
and with me in the studio today is
doctor ingo flessenko welcome dr
president kemp but the patient we just
saw in the report had an aneurysm that
was diagnosed by chance so no symptoms
whatsoever is that a normal case yes i
think that's quite normal because most
of the aneurysms don't cause any
symptoms they don't cause pain and so
they are found just by chance so i can
have an aneurysm for years and i don't
even realize um that i have one and it
can burst with no symptoms at all yeah
that's the fact and so that's why we try
to find them in
before
they are dangerous before they are
giving you any symptoms because if there
are symptoms it's really quite late and
how big actually is the risk of an
aneurysm to burst yeah we know that this
danger
directly depends to the size yeah and if
an aneurysm has a size of about five
centimeters or more then we know that we
should act
before it bursts before it goes yeah and
if the auto balloons and and get
ruptures and
are there there are some symptoms
because of the the rupturing of the
artery when the processing when it
ruptures then indeed then it's painful
you know most times it's an abdominal
pain or a back pain and if a patient
with this these symptoms comes through
first aid station or anything like that
then
everybody should be aware of the
possibility that an aneurysm is there
and it's bursting and then we have
some time to act and then we are active
and i can imagine that if this kind of
big vessel blood vessel just ruptures
that the patient just dies but is there
time to operate on a patient with a
ruptured aneurysm
we know that
most of the patients who have a rupture
don't reach the hospital but those
patients who come to the hospital
they have some time that we really
connect that we can try to rescue them
and are there some patients who have a
very great risk of developing an uh
aneurysm so so who's at the highest risk
yeah the highest risk is for for men
older than 65 years whoever smoked we
know that this group in the population
has some rate of aneurysms and so we try
to get a screening program for them and
then we can find the aneurysms in time
and what kind of screening programs
might there be some ct scan or
ultrasound no it's quite easy because we
can find these aneurysms just by a
sonographic
test or by a check and it's easy it's
not painful it's not dangerous there's
no x-ray and it's easy to do
and what about genetics our viewer from
croatia gabriel hatchet wants to know
and can you inherit an aneurysm from
your father or your mother for instance
it's possible we know that there are
some families in which
really aneurysms
are in several generations
so i think it's sensible it makes sense
that we
should look
for someone whose father for instance
has an aneurysm if this person itself
has an aneurysm as well and that's for
men and women okay so i said if you do
an ultrasound you see an enlarged order
and you want to treat this patient do
you always have to perform surgery or is
there some kind of medication you could
try first
oh with medication you can get it away
yeah but you can try to put down the
blood pressure and that's uh that makes
sense but
anyway if an aneurysm is bigger than
five centimeters in diameter for
instance then we should treat it with
surgery but we have a different kinds of
surgery yeah open surgery and
we have some methods with catheters and
which one is superior is the open
surgery still better than the invasive
new stuff
i wouldn't say that one method is better
than the other but nowadays we try to
use most times a catheter message the
endovascular method because it's less
demanding for the patient and it's less
stressful
their rehabilitation time is much
shorter
so nowadays i think 70 to 80 percent of
the patients can get an endovascular
treatment oh good thank you dr
pleasekeeper for being with us in the
studio today thank you
you